Übung 4
wandrutschen starten Sie in einem
hüftbreiten stand mit dem Rücken an eine
Wand gelehnt und stützen sie die Hände
seitlich am Rumpf ab die Füße sollten
dabei mit einem Abstand einer Fußlänge
von der Wand platziert sein rutschen sie
mit aufrechtem Oberkörper nach unten
sass die Knie leicht 45 bis 60° gebeugt
sind schieben Sie dabei die Knie nicht
über die Zehen hinaus und halten die
Knie immer in der Beinachse halten Sie
diese Position für 15 Sekunden und
drücken sich anschließend wieder nach
oben in die
Ausgangsstellung wiederholen Sie diese
Übung zehn mal mit einer Pausenzeit von
5 Sekunden zwischen den
Wiederholungen